bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
de honor qui a présenté en chine son
nouveau smartphone montra très bien de
ce smartphone en france pour l'instant
on va commencer un petit peu regarder
s'il ya dans le vent par ce qu'il va
arriver très rapidement chez nous et
c'est le honor but
alors au nord effectivement c'est une
marque qui propose beaucoup de
smartphones qui en sort énormément il ya
des modèles qui sortent tout au long de
l'année
il ya un grand modèle qui est sorti en
début d'année qui est annoncé en fin
d'année dernière c'est le honor view 10
la ceo nordiste qui va arriver qui est
le successeur du nord 9 est
effectivement chez au nord il y en a
pour tous les prix
on a des produits vraiment d'entrée de
gamme aux alentours des 100 euros
jusqu'à des produits qui sont beaucoup
mieux fait avec intelligence
artificielle notamment comme les
honneurs view 10 est là avec l'honneur
disent on va avoir un modèle bien boosté
puissant avec un processeur vraiment
boosté à l'intelligence artificielle un
produit qui a l'air en tout cas très
sexy de ce qu'on en voit au travers des
images qui sont disponibles dès
aujourd'hui sur le site chinois de au
nord alors je vais pas vous infliger
d'aller faire un petit tour son site
chinois des eaux nord par les chinois
déjà devenu papa chinois merci à google
la traduction de n'avoir vraiment aidé
et donc j'ai été voir un peu tout ça
alors venez voir le produit est tout cas
super cool le design est plutôt sympa et
ce qui est comme très intéressant là
dessus c'est qu'on va vraiment que honor
s'inspire vraiment de son grand frère
huawei parce que je sais pas si vous
savez mais au nord appartient à huawei
c'est une filiale est là pour le coup on
retrouve un petit peu les traits du p 20
ce qui est plutôt pas mal en soi alors
qu'est ce qu'on voit on voit
effectivement un très grand écran de
5,84 pouces c'est du lcd
c'est une dalle ltps de 1280 par 1080
pixels alors ce qui est super sympa
dessus c'est qu'on trouve vraiment ce
fameux design du web et 20 vous avez en
bas le lecteur d'empreintes digitales
juste en bas à positionner l'écran et la
fameuse encore on retrouve toujours sur
le haut du smartphone et cette fameuse
encoches qu'on retrouve sur le haut du
smartphone au dos vous avez un double
brillant assez premium très jolie je
dois le dire avec des couleurs qui je
sais pas s'ils vont trouver en tout cas
acquéreurs mais qui pour le coup sont
vraiment très original
alors il est disponible en quatre
couleurs en chine en tout cas le noir
bleu un espèce de turquoise rose et un
violet bleu espèce de mélange de
couleurs en tout cas ça vraiment le
mérite d'être très original et puissant
côté de la face avant c'est vraiment ce
grand écran ben amor dans le coup le
produit en tout cas d'un point de vue
design est assez bien réussi côté
puissance mettant dehors n'est pas forme
ans très intéressante avec un kirin 970
couplé à 6 g
anne le keirin 270 et boosté à
l'intelligence artificielle alors ça
c'est un petit peu le cheval de bataille
de honor et puis tous les constructeurs
ça m'amuse ont pu se développer là de
son artificier alors qu'est ce qu'on va
pouvoir faire avec notamment de la
reconnaissance de scène pour
l'optimisation des photos votre
smartphone va être capable de
reconnaître un paysage pense que vous
allez prendre en photo de reconnaître
des fleurs de reconnaître un plat de la
nourriture quoi que ce soit tout
simplement pour vraiment optimisé la
calibration au niveau colorimétrique la
lumière pourrait avoir quelque chose de
complètement optimisé d'un point de vue
logiciel
donc ça c'est vraiment intéressant alors
après mais aussi plein d'autres choses
qu'on peut faire avec à l'intelligence
artificielle scanner est l'étiquette
d'une bouteille pour pouvoir donner plus
d'information sur le vin pouvoir
traduire très facilement un texte
notamment pourquoi pas un texte en
chinois il ya pas mal de possibilités et
c'est vrai que on a tout un univers qui
s'ouvre à nous avec cette fameuse à
l'intelligence artificielle et ça au
nord l'a bien compris huawei l'a bien
compris ils travaillent vraiment dans ce
sens là pour apporter des solutions
toujours plus intéressantes et ceux qui
urinent 970 beaucoup fait vraiment bien
la fin là dessus côté stockage est
disponible en deux versions 64 giga 128
giga il a une batterie de 3400 millan
terreur en cuivre est fondamentalement
faire bien la faire un port jack
toujours pour ceux qui aiment le casque
qu'on branche directement dessus
soyez rassurés il ya toujours la partie
une prise usb type c'est pour pouvoir
leur charge et du bluetooth 4.2 et ont
tous un android aurait eu huit points
avec une surcouche maison est mu 8
points à l'arrière vous avez un double
objectif photo un rgb en couleurs pour
faire simple c'est du 16 mégapixels
couplé à un objectif monochrome de 24
mégapixels les deux ouvrant à f 1.8 pour
faire très simple du point de vue
d'ouverture plus vous descendez en
chiffres et plus ça va être lumineux
donc un f 1.8 ça devrait vraiment faire
la faire permet d'avoir des photos de
bonne qualité suffisamment lumineuse
n'avait pas acheté dans le noir comme
avec un bruit comme un pro mais en tout
cas ça va vraiment bien faire la faire
alban vous trouvez un capteur couleurs
de 24 mégapixels avec une ouverture de f
2.0
là ça va aussi faire la faire on va
moins aller chercher la fête de l'huma
youtube est bon voire une fois de plus
loin de celle fille enfin quelques
souvenirs ça va très bien à faire
notamment au niveau de la caméra avant
on retrouve de la reconnaissance faciale
côté tarifs maintenant il est disponible
en chine en 64 giga à 2
il s'y sent ul soit à peu près 3 134
euros hors taxes et 128 giga à trois
mille yuan soit à peu près 300 86 euros
hors taxes
alors il va être présenté le 15 mai
prochain à londres
on connaîtra vraiment le tarif chez nous
en france on imagine très bien car ils
supérieurs à 400 euros
434 144 50 euros avec de toute façon
cachée au nord comme à chaque fois des
offres de reprise vous permettra de le
financer un peu plus facilement voilà un
petit peu la fourchette qu'on devrait
avoir en termes de budget et pour voir
la fiche technique voir la puissance par
tout ce qu'on a à l'intérieur réellement
ce sera pas un produit qui sera
particulièrement cher toute façon c'est
vraiment le défi de huawei et de honor
c'est d'avoir des produits qui sont bien
positionnées huawei on est plus sur des
produits plus haut de gamme avec plus de
finition notamment au niveau des caméras
là par exemple avec le pépin pros ils
vont chercher effectivement une
ouverture toujours une base pour quelque
chose de beaucoup plus lumineux
les trois objectifs arrière là c'est pas
du tout la stratégie des eaux nord la
stratégie d honneur ce taux de 2 capté
le grand public qui veut des très bons
produits mais à des prix abordables nous
et des smartphones qui vont coûter 130
140 euros un smartphone qui vont vous
coûter 450 peut-être 500 euros voilà un
petit peu la stratégie de honor pour moi
ce smartphone il ya vraiment des points
positifs
déjà c'est la puissance on s'adresse au
gamer si vous voulez avoir un jeu fluide
quelque chose qui tourne avec pas trop
de ralenti puis vraiment pour vous
amuser avec à exploiter réellement vous
n'allez pas être déçus en utilisant le
quirinal cent soixante dix couples assis
giga de ram ça sera vraiment bien la
faire côté photo c'est vraiment honnête
on va pouvoir shooter dans de bonnes
conditions même en ayant de la faible
luminosité
c'est l'intelligence artificielle est
toujours de la partie on l'a vu déjà que
view dix ans c'était vraiment un produit
qui était boosté à l'intelligence
artificielle huawei honor vont continuer
vraiment aller dans ce sens parce que
c'est vraiment un point d'amélioration
qui est très intéressant puis c'est
vraiment l'avenir des smartphones des
smartphones toujours plus intelligent
pour nous aider au quotidien dans toutes
nos tâches l'écran est plutôt pas mal
aussi
et puis surtout le design arrière ce
côté un petit peu bicolore est scooté
brillance assez sympa alors ça plaira
pas forcément à tout le monde mais si
vous prenez en voir par exemple ou en
bleu c'est assez passe partout si vous
aimez les couleurs plus fantaisie vous
pourrez aussi vous faire plaisir
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez
parce que moi je trouve en tout cas sans
papiers de ce qu'on a vu de ces
présentations en chine et de cette fiche
technique je trouve vraiment cool assez
sexy et je pense qu'on va trouver
preneur dites moi ce que vous en pensez
en commentaire est ce que vous pourriez
vous laisser tenter par un nouveau aux
nordistes
ce que vous avez d'autres produits de
chez au nord on peut imaginer
liu 17 c'est le 7e art africain mark
tous les côtés mark et moi tout ça en
commentaire comme d'habitude vous invite
à laisser des jolies pose bien
évidemment à vous abonner parce qu'on va
rester connecté on va parler toujours
plus de produits hi tech il ya beaucoup
de choses à venir goûter à dire donc
restez connectés d'ici là soyez sages
portez vous bien
je vous embrasse et à très bientôt ciao
[Musique]